alors il n'y a pas de mode d'emploi pour
faire face est un drame comme celui de
lac mégantic la détermination et la
compassion de la mairesse de l'époque
que les trois laroche et de ma prochaine
invité l'ex première ministre pauline
marois ont été salués comme à peu près
de nous tous madame marois a pris à la
télévision en se levant le 6 juillet ce
qui venait de se passer elle était avec
nous en studio ce soit madame marois
bonsoir dans sa sélection alors
rapidement le matin du 6 vous émettez le
souhait d'aller sur place mais sans
flafla sens tout le protocole qui
accompagne la visite d'une première mine
et oui dans quel état d'esprit vous
abordez le d'abord - envoyant seul matin
je me suis dit c'est pas possible qu'ils
aient pas des gens qui soient pas
décédée dans cet événement là mais je ne
savais pas ce moment là j'ai appelé
immédiatement d'abord la sécurité
publique mon ministre n'était pas là
parce qu'il était à l'extérieur mais
tous les toute la sécurité publique
s'était mis en branle un c'était
immédiat et d'ailleurs c'est remarquable
d'efficacité était très fier de nos de
nos services gouvernementaux j'ai parlé
à la chef de cabinet du ministre et
jésus écoute moi je vais immédiatement
parlé à la mairesse qui est là bas et je
aller mais on va pas aller avec tout le
protocole là pour déranger alors j'ai
parlé à la mairesse le matin peut-être
pas 10h30 aux as parce que ma
préoccupation est évidemment c'était les
gens s qui avait des morts et combien
puis quelle est l ordre de la tragédie
finalement les bonnes soeurs âgées de 10
et des voix là et moi je voulais surtout
produire commencé après ça a aidé alors
j'ai parlé jeudi quand vous jugerez que
c'est correct d'y aller que vous pouvez
vous accueillir je veux absolument vous
voir je veux aller voir l'état de
situation mais je veux pas de cela fla
je riais de ça puis il ya pas de
protocole je vais être avec une attachée
de presse
j'avais du personnel du bureau de réjean
hébert qui était député ministre dans
les gens sherbrooke j'avais des jambes
dans la région alors je suis atterri en
fin d'après-midi une me sens que c'était
un samedi
je peux vérifier et immédiatement j'ai
rencontré madame colette roy laroche et
on a eu je pense que le contact a été
immédiatement très positif comme vous
dites y'a pas de il ya pas de catalogue
il n'y a pas de film il n'y a pas de
mode d'emploi
alors il faut y aller avait avait
le choeur la compassion et l'instant
c'était la première ministre qui était
sur le terrain c'était la travailleuse
sociale
les deux c'est pas mal ouais c'était les
deux et ça a toujours été comme ça que
j'ai travaillé dans cette situation là
et pour moi c'était d'abord les
personnes dont il fallait s'occuper il y
avait les battues il y avait le coeur de
la ville qui était défait il y avait
l'environnement qui étaient atteints
tous assez préoccupante fallait
évidemment s'en préoccuper aussi mais
d'abord les gens concernés vous dites
s'occuper des gens mais agir vite aussi
c'est une leçon des gestions crise que
vous avez faites au gouvernement c'est
que faut agir vite pour agir une leçon
des gestions de crise qu'il ya eu dans
notre gouvernement par le passé on pense
le verglas évidemment c'est assez
important il ya eu des inondations même
des gouvernements précédents
il faut agir tôt au départ mobiliser
toutes les ressources utiles et
nécessaires
que ce soit dans code et de tous les
services policiers de sécurité et cetera
les services incendie évidemment la
sécurité civile mobiliser aussi les
services sociaux
surtout quand on a des gens qui vivent
une situation aussi dramatique est aussi
catastrophique au plan humain alors agir
vite mobilisés choisir des intervenants
qui vont être capables d'intervenir avec
les pouvoirs et l'autorité pour le faire
donc ce serait aux plus hautes instances
de l'état absolument vous réunissiez des
gens qui avaient droit d secrétaire
général du gouvernement c'est à dire le
plus haut fonctionnaire du gouvernement
monsieur st gelais avait reçu le mandat
immédiatement on s'était parlé de nommer
des gens qui viendraient des différents
ministères et qui auraient une autorité
suffisante pour prendre des décisions
sans soins ça me paraît devoir se
référer à des responsables ici et là est
ce que ça veut dire agir vite est ce que
ça veut dire mettre de côté la
bureaucratie les 46 formulaire qu'il
faut remplir pour prendre une décision
c'est exactement la décision que j'ai
prise peux vous le dire avec mon
secrétaire général avec mon cabinet mon
cabinet a aussi mis en place une petite
cellule
les chefs de cabinet des ministres
responsables affermissent pas le
transport sécurité publique santé
services sociaux se parlait
fois par jour bon la première chose que
j'ai fait j'ai dit à monsieur st gelais
mon secrétaire général j'étais là on va
dégager une somme immédiatement
je ne veux que personne me mettre des
bâtons dans les roues
et qu'on ne dise on va utiliser tel
programme tellement je sais comment ça
marche
j'ai dirigé par faye g j'ai présidé à la
gestion de fait de 12 ministères dont
certains très complexe puis quand il
faut commencer à monter dans la
hiérarchie pour obtenir une autorisation
ça prend un temps fou on s'en chargeant
les virgules dans les fleurs du tapis
comme on dit parfois
alors moi je dis on va dégager une somme
immédiatement on va rendre disponible de
l'argent pour les gens parce que c'est
bien beau d'avoir offert des services et
il faut le faire mais là les gens y
avait pas seulement il y avait des gens
qui étaient décédés mais elle avait les
gens qui avaient dû quitter il pénètre
et y en avait un grand nombre qui ont dû
être évacués par c'était trop dangereux
les gaz et s'est alors immédiatement à
dégager une somme on envoyer des gens de
haut niveau donc capable de prendre des
décisions et dans les premiers jours il
y avait déjà des chèques d'amy
quand ce ne serait que de se retrouver
des vêtements que de de pouvoir aller à
s'acheter d'épicerie manger au
restaurant ou quoi que ce soit même si
on offrait des hébergements temporaires
il fallait à faire plus que ça donc à
peine quelques jours plus tard les gens
avaient accès à cela il y avait une
certaine forme de contrôle ça va de soi
mais il n'y avait pas d' en charge au
plan de la bureaucratie et
d'administration je peux vous l'assurer
je dis à mes amis ministres après ça on
verra quel programme aurait pu
s'appliquer
puis on ira vers les l'argent avait des
besoins pressants et pas de répondre à
ces besoins l'enseignement depuis cinq
ans beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les
ponts notamment l'acquittement des trois
hommes qui était en procès le conducteur
superviseur je pense et un autre employé
vous vous êtes dit quand je me suis tu
me trompes heureuses de leur
acquittement d'une certaine façon
pourquoi vous êtes heureuse c'est un peu
comme j'écoutais monsieur cuisine tout à
l'heure je pense comme lui aussi je
pense que c'était pas leur niveau que
devait porter la responsabilité
mais c'était au niveau des propriétaires
des gestionnaires des directeurs
de la mma qui n'avait pas posé les
gestes qu'il fallait pour assurer la
sécurité de ses convois parce qu'il ya
plusieurs convois qui est passée par là
qu mégantic et par ailleurs et qui
présentait un très grand risque
or ces gens-là n'assumez pas leurs
responsabilités ces personnes là qu'on
devrait pouvoir blâmer programmés mais
non je sais on reste quelque chose de
découper oui c'est vrai il reste quelque
chose qui n'est pas terminé mais en même
temps il ya quand même un procès y'a bon
et je sais qu'il ya des frais qui leur
sont qui doivent payer et cetera il ya
des poursuites uzi qui continue par
ailleurs et j'espère qu effectivement
ces poursuites mèneront à certains
résultats et que je sais sera rendue
nous avons découvert colette roy laroche
pendant cette tragédie une mairesse avec
qui vous avez un semble être un énorme
respect vous avez découvert comme nous
cette femme-là absolue détermination
sont résilients absolument détermination
résilience un leadership rassurant dans
des circonstances comme celles là il
faut qu'on a quelqu'un en qui on va
avoir confiance et qui va qu'ils veulent
on vous dont on va sentir cette façon là
de faire les choses et je pense que
c'était la force de colette roy laroche
c'est sa force
ce leadership je dirais tranquille calme
rassurant
une humanité qui se dégageait de son
comportement de sa façon de faire je les
ai vus travailler avec ses
collaborateurs elle faisait confiance à
ces gens et posaient des questions
bien sûr ça l'est soit mais on sentait
qu'elle voulait travailler en équipe
miser sur la solidarité miser sur la
concertation et c'était sa grande force
une force une femme que ken absolument
admirable on avait l'impression qu'il
était toujours en contrôle
je sais bien que ça bouge et en daim
pesait pas toujours évident et qui était
je devrais y avait une certaine humilité
dans son camping la main parce
qu'accepter de de demander conseil
de se faire proposer des choses ensuite
évidemment de prendre ses décisions ça
prend du multi vous savez pour elle ne
savait pas tout elle voulait apprendre
et savoir comment faire les choses
absolument prendre confiance et on va
terminer là dessus plutôt avoir
confiance envers le système on note qu
il y a encore des trains qui partent
alors qu'ils devraient être arrêtées
majoritairement dans des gares de triage
le soit mais on a l'impression d'une
certaine façon qu'il ya une
réglementation qui existe depuis lé pas
nécessairement impliquer et puis dès le
départ
après cet événement il ya eu des
échanges avec le gouvernement fédéral de
la part de notre gouvernement puis a eu
des rencontres avec d'autres provinces
et cetera
puis on a fait des représentations
auprès d'ottawa pour qu'ils adoptent des
mesures beaucoup plus sévère des
règlements des lois s'il le faut le
problème c'est que on l'adoptent où on
est d'accord mais on n'applique pas
d'application c'est l'application et je
pense qu'il ya une énorme responsabilité
sur les épaules du gouvernement fédéral
il devrait agir à mes gants c'est comme
ailleurs parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres endroits au québec des petites
municipalités des muscles de plus grande
taille où il ya des trains qui circulent
avec des produits dangereux même si on
ralentit et cetera
si les mesures de base ne sont pas
appliquées c'est sûr que le risque est
très élevé et perdre des vies comme on
l'a fait à la cliente sais que c'est
inacceptable c'est là dessus qu'on se
quitte mais la marouette merci d'avoir
fait le détour par notre m'a fait
plaisir et ce que je peut saluer les
gens de mais quand il faut leur dire ma
solidarité et mon amitié et mon respect
et dire merci à une grande mairesse
colette roy laroche
le message est fait merci maman